what exactly happened to Bill Maher is a
question that many of you have been
writing to me and asking because he has
made some increasingly strange comments
lately that don't really seem to fit
with the perception of Bill Maher but I
actually am going to show you today
um a transcript from an interview I
remember watching that Bill Maher did 18
years ago and I am going to argue that
Bill Maher hasn't really changed he's
just sort of shifted his focus and
shifted what he talks about but it's the
same Bill Maher today that it was in the
past so first and foremost Bill Maher
recently appeared uh with Fran Lebowitz
on his podcast it was an interesting
conversation but I disagree with a lot
of things that Bill Maher is saying
increasingly doesn't mean I I disagree
with him on everything but increasingly
he's saying things that don't really
make a lot of sense here he was sort of
glamorizing Ron DeSantis take a listen
to this I mean compared to Trump he
doesn't have a giant ass he has hair you
know he's got uh I mean compared to
Trump he has policies which Trump
doesn't have and the policies are really
horrible well he does a lot of
performative art yes some of it is is a
reaction to policies that were insane to
begin with like the don't say Gabe sure
Ron DeSantis does some performative
stuff but it's because the left forced
him to you know first of all it doesn't
say that and it doesn't say don't say
gay
um parents were not look he does a lot
of stupid things I agree he campaigned
for election deniers that's a big red
flag with me yeah but parents were not
unreasonably concerned that schools had
become a place where kids were being
exposed to ideas about gender and race
that were completely inappropriate for
someone three years old you're making my
case for me they may have been however I
don't think I think he does these things
to distract from his real policies which
are
let's stop Social Security cut Medicare
you know those are the real things look
and especially in Florida where 90 of
the people already on Social Security
right you're saying he's for maybe maybe
the party is he is too I mean he is too
I mean I'm less worried about him so you
know kind of glamorizing Rhonda santis
and sure he does some crazy stuff but a
lot of it is because he's being forced
into doing it by the woke left or
whatever the case may be and then he
goes into uh the topic of covid and
covid rules all turned out to be stupid
maybe this maybe this makes people
understand why some of us who called out
a lot of the uh nonsense with how we
handled covid we're so skeptical because
we've done stupid Health theater for a
long time it's not new we've handled
almost every Health crisis badly not all
of them
um and you know I found it just arrogant
to have such a bad record in the past
with health matters now some of what
Bill Maher is saying here isn't wrong
the U.S has a bad record of handling
Health emergencies there was a lot of
uncertainty in communication problems
and all of these different things the
problem is that Bill Maher presents it
all in a way that opens the door to the
science deniers and the um anti-vaxxers
and all of it and he is being used in
that way just tell me just do what we
say when have we ever been wrong and
then it's like oh okay uh we're washing
the mail and they told us you know like
wear any kind of mask they're all good
just some bandana put a diaper on your
head doesn't matter everything's fine
and I remember
um don't touch your face it was about a
big hit song for about a year don't
touch your face I'm not up on which
covet rules you were opposed to
they all turned out to be stupid not all
which ones it was not on the mail no oh
no they just found they just did a study
the masks unless they were n95 and maybe
not even them useless
um you know I I stopped wearing a
masculine you don't have to wear it
anymore and you all remember it's all
it's all degrees and it's well no The
Masks are increasingly less effective
the lower quality they are and we have
studies and we know that but it's
exactly this type of black and white
thinking offhanded flippant black and
white thinking that opens the door to
people who believe anything to say oh I
was right I was right but
but that's just but I the vaccines I'm
glad there were the vaccines yes I'm
glad there were vaccines I don't don't
plea you know what it's if that's your
choice great uh there are some vaccines
I would love to have and might need and
would fight you for but if I don't but I
should be able to make my own medical
decisions you are not a nurse okay
you're not in a hospital you know I
think it depends who you are you know uh
right well you're saying they would have
to get the best yes well I mean okay but
here's something stupid we did that
other countries didn't do countries I
think you would respect by the way
countries you're going to I'm going to
do your plugs what a great segue but
like
you're a much more recognized natural
immunity if you're a nurse and you had
it naturally at the beginning which a
lot of nurses did then it was stupid and
pointless and yeah you know it wasn't
really stupid and pointless because if
you had it at the beginning by the time
that the vaccines were out we started to
see an evolution to different variants
and as we know four or five months after
that the vaccine's effectiveness when it
came to preventing infection was
dramatically lower so your immunity uh
15 months later to a variant that is not
even actually the variant that's out
there anymore isn't going to be
particularly useful so anyway the point
here is I don't I'm not saying Bill
Maher's a bad guy and I'm not saying
he's wrong about everything but he has
had this streak particularly on medical
stuff for a very long time let me
present to you an exhibit okay I
remember watching this interview and I
went and searched for a clip I couldn't
find a clip but I found a transcript 18
years ago in 2005 Bill Maher was
interviewed by Larry King
and he claims that the flu shot makes
Alzheimer's more likely and says aspirin
is bad now you might say David that's
Bill Maher would never say that let's
put up the transcript on the screen Bill
Maher says well I hate to tell you Larry
but if you have a flu shot for more than
five years in a row there's 10 times the
likelihood that you'll get Alzheimer's
disease I would stop getting your and
King says what did you say and Mara says
that went better than in rehearsal but
it was still good absolutely no the
defense against the against disease is
to have a strong immune system a flu
shot compromises your immune system now
this has been studied the flu shot
reduces the risk for for Alzheimer's
among those age 65 plus this has been
studied this it's it's not even
something Bill Maher brought up that
hadn't been studying said it has been
studied we know that that is not true
okay this was Bill Maher 18 years ago
and then Larry King says so you don't
take any Western medicine don't take an
aspirin and Bill Maher says never an
aspirin no thousands of people die from
aspirin every year
and King says how do you treat illness
and Bill Maher says I promise you if you
get a headache the reason for the
headache is not aspirin deficiency which
I remember being 20 and watching this
and saying Bill Maher can't be this
stupid right imagine applying that idea
listen the reason you have cancer is not
a chemo deficiency so why would you give
someone chemo well because that's not
how medication Works medication is not
about giving you something you were
deficient in medications work in a lot
of different ways from monoclonal
antibodies to uh antibiotics so it's
it's not about I lack aspirin my
headache is caused by a lack of aspirin
so I will cure the headache by taking
aspirin the idea that that's Bill Marsh
train of thought is very disturbing
because it's so stupid and then um Bill
Larry King says no of course not Bill
Maher says right so you're taking and
King says something to take the pain
away why is that bad and Bill Maher says
but why don't you find out the real root
of that pain and Larry King says well
while you're finding take the aspirin
which is actually a pretty funny line
from Larry King so the point here is
Bill Mars had this streak for a very
long time time it's not actually new
covid made it more of a focus for him
and I think that's where we are today